one of the worst feelings in a foreign
language is simply not
being able to understand what you're
hearing or reading
has that ever happened to you you were
talking to someone and suddenly realized
that
you have no idea what they said or maybe
you're in public and
hear an important announcement but for
the life of you you cannot
figure out what it means this is an
immensely frustrating experience for
sure
however if you felt this way let me
assure you that it's quite normal
and there's a way to ensure that going
forward these experiences will happen to
you
less and less often until they rarely
happen at all
hi i'm luca from lucampedal.com and
today i'm going to talk to you about how
you can improve your listening
comprehension
fast and efficiently but first let me
tell you a story
three years ago i visited budapest in
the summer
with my friend alessandra and during our
trip we decided to visit a small town
outside of the city at one point we were
at the train station
and needed to buy some tickets we went
to the ticket booth
where we found a woman sitting behind
the counter
i asked her for the tickets we needed in
hungarian but apparently the lady wasn't
having any of it for some reason she was
upset by my request
and would not give me what i was trying
to ask for even though i knew someone
garen at the time i could not understand
why she was so upset and the whole
incident left me feeling
a little bit confused fortunately after
many attempts i was able to
somehow get her to give me the tickets
and i never did figure out what she was
going on about though
or what i may have done wrong
frustrating
and awkward situations like the one i've
just mentioned
are uncomfortable enough when there's no
language barrier
however when the language barrier is
added to the mix
everything can feel much worse
especially when you aren't the one not
understanding
if you find yourself in a situation like
this here's three things
you should know one in quick exchanges
and brief conversations
there are always bound to be
misunderstandings the majority of our
daily interactions are usually filled
with lots of context and familiarity
with the people you're speaking to the
situations you're in and the subjects
you're talking about
however you're talking however when
you're talking to a person in a new
place
in an unfamiliar situation and in a
language you don't know well
it's inevitable that some important
information will be lost
in the exchange second sometimes the
misunderstanding has nothing to do with
you
and everything to do with the other
person some people are just rude and you
can't always account for that ahead of
time
luckily however the majority of native
speakers in any language are usually
quite nice to non-natives speaking to
them and
don't get angry like the ticket kiosk
woman did
third we often like to focus on the
worst possible outcome and that can make
interactions more difficult than they
have to be
it's unusual for example to language
learners to judge themselves too harshly
for small mistakes that the other person
does not notice or care about
many of the negative outcomes or
potential negative outcomes that we
focus on
tend to only happen in our heads all
that being said however
the best solution to avoiding such
situations in your life is to cultivate
excellent listening comprehension skills
that way the sheer depth of your
abilities will prevent
any and all misunderstandings even
before they start
so how do you develop excellent
listening comprehension skills
first be patient and prepare for a long
journey it takes time for your brain to
figure out the spoken flow of any
language
it's possible to fake good speaking
skills by using colloquialisms
some catch phrases and even throw in
some unusual words here and there but
it's much more difficult to fake your
ability to understand
you can certainly act like you
understand something you don't
but if you don't actually understand
pretending may only
lead to more problems so how much time
does it take to understand the language
automatically
a long time thousands and thousands of
hours
of good quality exposure to authentic
spoken language
it's a lot for sure but as soon as you
accept that fact
you'll be able to relax and actually get
to work on improving your skills
for the long run simultaneously read and
listen as much as you can
especially if you are a beginner the
reason for this is simple
at the very start if you just listen you
can't really tell
one word from the next and if you just
read you have
no idea how words sound as an adult you
can leverage your capacity to read
and harness it in conjunction with your
capacity
to listen a good listening and reading
practice is easy to develop
and if done the right way it's extremely
effective
you can do this with any language even
with exotic ones like chinese or
japanese since
there are tools like romanization that
can help you
get started on top of listening or
reading at the same time
you should also spend time just
listening without
reading at the same time why do i
recommend listening and reading as well
as listening by itself
because listening and reading is an
excellent way to start learning from a
piece of content
but it's not something that you'll need
to do forever in order to get value from
that content
once you've listened to and read
something you gain the benefit
of knowing at least the gist of what
that content is about
having this familiarity with the text
gives you the option of listening to the
audio alone
just to see if you still understand the
material
so if you listen to read and analyze
say five podcast episodes in a given
week you don't need to spend the
following week reading and listening to
the same five episodes again
instead you can start listening and
reading to a new set of five episodes
and use
just listening to review the earlier
podcasts in a new way
listening only in this way has a lot of
advantages
it's easy to do it can be done anywhere
you bring your phone
and it allows you to review the content
from your listening slash reading in a
new way
reinforcing your knowledge of words as
well as your listening comprehension
at the start of your new listening
practice it's more important to learn
consistently than it is to learn
intensely
however as you build proper habits and
improve your skills
intensity will need to become a priority
as well
when i talk about consistency i mean
spending at least
10 to 20 minutes each and every day
working on building your listening
skills
i know we're all busy but i truly
believe that anyone can find at least 10
minutes in their day
especially if they really want to
accomplish a goal if you're having
trouble starting the habit
i recommend connecting it to an existing
habit you already have and
that you do every day for example i have
a habit of
listening to polish audio every time i
do a workout
i work out at the same time every day so
connecting these habits together
really helps me make sure that my polish
listening practice
gets done once you develop a habit of
learning for at least
10 minutes a day then you can focus on
ramping up the intensity
and learning for a longer period of time
the great thing about listening is that
it can be practiced
with recorded audio so you can feasibly
do it
all day if you want to and of course the
more you do it
the better your skills will eventually
be this may seem counterintuitive
but my next bit of advice is to work on
your pronunciation
from the very beginning if you can most
people don't realize this but
pronunciation skills and listening
comprehension skills
are absolutely linked why because if you
can't pronounce a sound
you probably can't hear it in someone
else's speech
the more you know about how the sound
system of a language works the easier it
will be
to pick out the small subtle phonetic
details that differentiate similar words
or even slurred fast speech and that's
another thing
when we read written language we deceive
ourselves into thinking that
words are separate and distinct from one
another
in actual speech this is absolutely not
the case
in authentic spoken language there are
no gaps between words like there are
spaces on a written page
the sounds all run together in subtle
ways and
it is up to our brains to separate the
words in our heads
here's a quick example of this
phenomenon called connected speech
and linguistics just to give you a very
simple example let me put two words on
your screen
how do you think they're pronounced when
read together on the screen
you see two words separated by a space
black coffee but the reality is that you
read them as
black coffee one sound and the end of
black
merges with the first part of coffee
connected speech
like i just showed you is an easy detail
to miss but
it's extremely important when it comes
to understanding spoken language
focus on the big picture sometimes no
matter
how much we train ourselves to
understand a situation arises
in which we just can't grasp everything
and this is inevitable
hell it's pretty normal to misunderstand
even our native language sometimes but
what should we do in this situation well
the most important rule
don't panic even if you think you
understand nothing there's still a high
probability that there are cues and
clues around you that can help you
understand at least
something that's what happened to me in
budapest i didn't understand what the
lady was saying to me but i did grasp
a few random words relating to time and
this helped me realize that she was
probably asking me what time i wanted to
buy the ticket for
this combined with the fact that she
turned her screen to me with a list of
open departure times
helped me convey the information i
needed in order to purchase
my ticket so in the end i didn't
understand what she was saying maybe a
little bit of it but i was able to use
my surrounding context to fill in the
gaps when you feel lost in a
conversation
that's what you need to do as well look
for external cues even non-verbal or
physical ones that could indicate
meaning
piece them together like a puzzle and
you'll stand an excellent chance of
getting through the awkward situation
without any major problems when learning
a new skill
seek out a wide variety of experiences
when learning a new skill
people often talk about getting out of
your comfort zone
you may not ever have thought about it
but your listening skills have
a comfort zone too the things inside
your comfort zone represent what you can
understand
while the things outside of your comfort
zone represent what you can't understand
to improve your listening skills you
need to expand your comfort zone so that
the range of things you can understand
is as wide as possible though it may
seem intimidating
the only way to do this is to experience
the language
in as many varied contexts as possible
you may be nervous to talk to that tutor
that store clerk or that plumber in your
target language but if you don't
face those situations head on and see
what they're like
how will you ever be able to handle them
as nerve-wracking as getting out of your
comfort zone may be
it is important to realize that doing so
is the only way to build confidence
confidence is not something you have but
rather a state of mind
that comes from previous experience if
you don't have previous experience
it's hard to be confident and for that
reason it's essential that you seek out
as many new listening experiences as
possible
so you can develop true confidence in
your listening skills
smile and be honest with yourself what's
the first thing you think
when you don't understand something in
your target language why can't this
stuff get through my thick skull
oh no i'm such an idiot oh boy look at
those faces
something like that right as adults we
hate
the uncertainty of not knowing what's
going on
so we berate ourselves for not knowing
what we think we're supposed to
sometimes we try to remedy this by
faking it
smile nod and pretend that yes
we really did get that very funny joke
that that person was just trying to tell
but as i mentioned before that could
lead to problems
if people think you've understood
something when you in fact
haven't they could continue discussing
the same topics
never once realizing that you are
completely lost
so faking it is not the answer a better
approach
is to simply own the misunderstanding
smile
politely interrupt the person and ask
them to repeat
most people are very accommodating of
this and they'll be happy to repeat
themselves either
more slowly or using simpler terms
the key is being honest the mere act of
saying
sorry i didn't get that releases a lot
of pressure
remember we're all human and we all make
mistakes our real strength as a species
is collaboration
and collaboration flourishes with
honesty
and transparency words being written or
spoken
are the building blocks of language the
more words you know the more
combinations of words you get exposed to
the better your listening comprehension
will ultimately be
make sure you spend a given amount of
time reading every single day
in order to increase your vocabulary
just as with listening you need to aim
for consistency first
and then consistency and intensity later
starting with 15 minutes of reading a
day and then increase it as you get
more comfortable language learning
content can come in a wide
range of difficulties this depends on a
number of factors ranging from
vocab used topic but also the
environment and the circumstances
compare listening to a language learning
podcast
made for non-native speakers with a news
broadcast something made entirely for
natives
or compare listening to one person talk
directly to you versus
listening to an entire group of people
talk amongst themselves
the native content is always harder and
the native content with more speakers
is even harder than that my point here
is that to become
a better listener you need to gradually
increase the difficulty of the kinds of
content you listen to
at first you'll need to start with slow
clear audio resources for learners but
you'll eventually need to move on to
more complex things
on more complex topics for more advanced
speakers
and with greater numbers of people to
listen to
at once now let me do a quick recap
understanding any foreign language
is a process that requires lots of time
and exposure
make sure you start building your
listening comprehension activity from
the very beginning listen while reading
first building vocabulary and
comprehension
then listen to what you have already
understood to reinforce your listening
comprehension
your attention to detail and your
vocabulary work on your pronunciation
too
because understanding subtle phonetic
details will help you better understand
the language that you hear
work on your confidence by facing as
many experiences as you can face the
unknown and learn to identify context
clues whenever you feel lost
when you are lost learn to smile and be
upfront
about not understanding it happens build
your listening comprehension
one step at a time starting with easy
materials for learners but gradually
moving on to more complex materials for
natives
so what do you think do you have stories
where not
understanding your target language led
to a funny situation
how did you solve it let me know in the
comments don't forget to like
subscribe and share if you enjoy the
video and remember to check the
description box for a link to an awesome
article with script
and video and more funny and cool
examples
and as always thanks for watching
you